[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you
oh
what is going on here
okay want to play
[Music]
high five dude
okay what is up everyone this is zeki
from geek culture and today we've got
something very special lined up for you
we got the marvel legends series power
gauntlet by hasbro so before we get
right into the power dollar we're going
to show you the infinity gauntlet that
was issued last year
all right this is how it looks you can
see
the bronze-ish
very medieval very heavy metal kind of
look with the infinity stones so if you
watch avengers end game you guys will be
very familiar with what this is this is
the power gauntlet that tony stark and
bruce banner built
to house an infinity stones in order to
defeat shadows
right off the bat you can see that the
power gauntlet has this nice red glossy
shine
and matte gold paint which really
resembles the iron man suit
now with that being said i think hasbro
did a very good job with the detail it
looks as if it came out from the movie
um you can see uh the design on the
infinity stones
like the little smoke like kind of gear
looking things on the articulation of
the fingers and not to mention the
rubberized grips which i think you know
just it's just cool so
the power corner is more futuristic
looking of course this was made by tony
stark and bruce balance so you know you
got to give credit to them right
you can see that it's very
robotic things like that
compared to the infinity gauntlet which
is
made by the gods per se or
medieval more
heavy battle you know i'm talking about
so as you can see that the infinity
stones are exactly the same as how it
would be on the infinity gauntlet
however don't forget that the power gun
is actually on the right hand side so
the border is actually reversed
so following the thumb to the pinky this
is the time power space reality mind and
soul stone
not to mention there's some movie
inspired sound effects in this power
gauntlet that really makes you feel that
you know you're already holding that
power goblet
too powerful in that sense so
yes sir
and that's not the only thing
that tells you it fits like a glove
all you need to do is just push up
it sounds like small gears working um
it's very technology kind of vibe
futuristic robotic kind of sounds to it
while the arctic when you articulate the
fingers or the infinity gauntlet it
sounds really chunky and clunky like
like chains moving around
oh yeah with that being said it really
does look like
something
superheroes uh made and then we have the
very villainous
terror vibing
infinity gauntlet here so
yeah
so
hasbro has heard you and what they have
done was improve the playability of the
power gauntlet as compared to the
infinity gauntlet those with shorter
reach or even have smaller hands you
need not be afraid anymore
it won't slip out
you can grab a hold of it easily and
yeah just just have a blast with it and
have fun
[Music]
so you guys are wondering how much this
would cost well
for starters the infinity gauntlet was
99 us dollars so
this will also be u.s 99
so we're all happy with that now in
terms of availability for singaporeans
you guys are very very very lucky
because this is available now for
singapore 199
and those who are in america or
international it will be available
september onwards so if you're a true
believer please like comment share
subscribe this is zaki from geek culture
signing off
well that's a moment